So let's see how we can
actually compute that.
Again remember, we are looking for
eight parameters.
This is equal to 1 which
basically is a scale factor and
always known to be equal to one.
We need to set up a system
of linear equations like so
where basically Is equal to b.
And how would we do this?
Well, h is our unknowns.
So basically what we
would need to know is,
where is the vector of Nodes h is
basically all of the values a, b, c,
d, e, f, g, h, the eight things,
and that's my vector.
What would be the other two terms?
Well, basically we need eight equations.
But more the better.
So these are eight equations now.
But if you had more of them, what,
how would we get more of them?
We actually can sample information
from the images ourselves.
So, can actually compute all of this,
but what we want to do is,
if we had more of them, we can
actually come up with better solution.
So, we need to solve for h here.
I need to know A, and I need to know b.
And again those things are available
because I have the pair of images.
And of, of course,
if it's an over-constraint,
I can actually get more samples.
What I can do basically is makes
this into a least squares solution,
where basically I'll solve it for a lot
of information and of course look for
the minimum of the least
squares solution.